We will discuss two different variants of the
queueing lock the first one we'll talk about is
the array-based queueing lock, and this is due
to Anderson. And I'll refer to it as Anderson's
lock later on as well. Associated with each lock L is an array of flags. And
the size of this array is equal to the number of processes in the SMP. So if you
have a an N-way multiprocessor, then you have N elements in the circular
flags array. And this flags array serves as a circular queue. For N-queuing the
requesters that are requesting this particular
lock L. So every lock has associated
with it, this flags array and it's really intuitive that since we have utmost
we have N processors in this multiprocessor. We can have utmost
N requests simultaneously waiting for this particular lock so the size of the
data structure, the flags data structure is equal to N where nN is the number of
processors in the multiprocessor. Now each element in this flags
array can be one of two states. One state is the has-locks state.
And the other state is a must-wait state. Has-lock
says that whoever is waiting on a particular slot
has the lock. So this particular entity let's say,
is hl. And that means that whichever processor happens
to be waiting on this particular slot is a
current winner of the lock and is using the
lock. On the other hand, must-wait is indicating that
if a processor has must-wait as the. Entry in this
particular element of the array, and is waiting on
this particular slot, that means that the processor has to
wait. You guessed it. There can be exactly one
processor that can be in the hl happy state because
it's a mutually exclusive lock. And therefore. Utmost one
processor can have a lock at a time, and all
the others should be waiting. And, so what we
do is, in order to, when we get this lock.
To initialize the lock, what we do is
we initialize the lock data structure, this array
data structure. The flags of array data structure
which represents a circular queue by marking one slot
as hl. And all the others as must-wait. An important point I want you all to
notice, is that the slots are not statically
associated with any particular processor. As requesters come in,
they're going to line up in this flags array at the spot that they get
in the next available slot. The key point is that there is the unique
spot that is available for every waiting
processor. But it is not statically assigned
and we'll see. How requests get formed using this circular queue in a minute.